Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P. We haven't heard from
him for a while. But Eric from Mass. Eric from
Massachusetts, who has been insisting for years,
I'm about to get sued. I'm about to get arrested.
I'm about to get imprisoned because I, quote,
promoted the vaccines by which he means I
reported the scientific information about
them. He now it's really going to happen
now. I'm really about to get arrested now.
Speaker 4: And given a terrible mess.
Get ready. The Brunson case from the
Supreme Court is about to come through
and all your buddies, your government
wins you normal and every day is going to be all
over the place and fired and probably arrested.
What they did was illegal.
Speaker 1: And what did
they what did they and I do.
Speaker 4: You're on record saying
you want to go by the Constitution and well, you
probably know all this. You just hide it from your
people because the Democrat Party is
burning down just like authoritarianism.
Republicans are authoritarian, a scientist is
authoritarian. When you let people go to work,
not wear masks, not have to get vaccinated.
Speaker 1: Now, this guy is obsessed, huh?
Speaker 4: Man, you have a backwards,
backwards outlook on life. You destroyed
people's lives. Democrats destroyed the country.
Speaker 1: I'm not even a Democrat. And I had no
no influence whatsoever on policy. So I
don't know how I destroyed anyone's life.
Speaker 4: Or destroyed people's lives. All over
the common cold. I mean, you know, you talk about
critical thinking. How can you possibly critically
think that some guy on TV tells you to get a shot
of Oprah who gets all of this stuff? Oh, you get
either of the dirt or five or six in a bathroom.
You can't mix and match drums. Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. Someone on the TV said you could.
Speaker 1: So Eric from Mass still fully on. And
very, very dangerous stuff going on over there.
But I am standing by for when they take me away
in handcuffs. Let's see if and when it happens.
I'm sure it will be much to Eric's delight if it
does. We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about this new low confidence report
from the Department of Energy about the origins
of COVID. We will talk about the NPR layoffs and
what is going on in media with the layoffs. And we
will give you the latest on Senator John Fetterman
and his path to recovery. All of those stories and
more on the bonus show. Get the bonus show, folks.
Get the bonus show. Sign up at Join Pack Mint.com.
You can use the coupon code. Please no more
Trump. That's the code. All one word. No spaces,
please. No more Trump. It'll save you a bundle
and then we'll see you on the bonus, Jeff.